the world has changed Society miss Jade
you married a wild spirit trying to tame
them his news this restlessness of who
was it has to be a thing of the past the
Marquis too fragile you keep telling me
yourself one more scandal one more
national embarrassment and it would all
be over
I Know Who I am
a woman for the modern age free to live
to the love free to break away who has
done more damage to the monarchy me with
my willfulness or you lost with your
inhumanity Britain has changed beyond
recognition
but yet the monarchy continues its
pre-war routines as though nothing has
happened what is it that you'd have me
change everything
[Music]
to do nothing is often the best course
of action history was not made by those
who did nothing
I think people have a right to know
about their leaders especially ones that
can't be thrown out with free and fair
elections I will earn their respect
right now I am currently out ranked by
my eight-year-old son
[Music]
there is no possibility of my forgiving
you the question is
how on earth can you forgive yourself
[Music]
you
[Music]
you